[Music]
we did have a lot of fun fighting
Hillary didn't we
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
are those with Trump supporters
repeatedly calling for the prosecution
of Hillary Clinton now they've been
doing this now for a number of years and
last night the president he continued
his call for the Justice Department to
investigate Hillary Clinton now this
following the bombshell allegation she
stole literally stole the election the
primary election from Bernie Sanders the
president tweeted quote Donna Brazile
just stated the DNC rigged the system to
illegally steal the primary from Bernie
Sanders bought and paid for by crooked
Hillary this is real collusion and real
dishonesty major violation of campaign
finance laws and money laundering where
is our Justice Department joining us now
is Fox News contributor former
presidential candidate Herman Cain
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi Pam
let's go to you so now we have the
issues that I just mentioned campaign
finance laws were they broken then we've
got the issue on the phony dossier and
that she funneled money through a law
firm in that particular case with
Russian propaganda to influence the
election now we know that they knew the
bribery extortion money laundering
kickbacks was all happening and they
still allowed uranium one to go through
and then of course the email server
scandal about if Pam Bondi Attorney
General says Sean Hannity I want 33,000
emails and I delete them and bleach pit
them and I break up my my blackberry in
my my iPhone you're throwing me in jail
I'm suspecting it's gonna be an all-out
investigation and and you know you and
Gregg Jarrett laid out this case so
beautifully by the way you genius but
you know Shonda the American people
deserve to know I saw a headline and it
read on a competing station it said
Trump wants to go after political
enemies no president Trump wants the
truth and the American people deserve to
know the truth and as Attorney General
of the state of Florida I believe in the
rule of law and I have got to have
complete faith that our United States
Attorney General jeff Sessions Rod
Rosenstein they are going to have to dig
they're going to continue to see it
better
digging right now because Sean we have
got to find out the truth for the
brilliant case that you laid out take
this has nothing to do with politics
this has to do with potential law
violations and only the Justice
Department can get their hands on all
these documents you're right
Herman Cain what it is about the rule of
law and the equal application of the
rule of law and the American people are
pretty smart I think most Americans knew
subpoenaed emails that were deleted and
bleached bitten hammers to devices that
was a good sign
then on uranium one it never made sense
to give 20% of our uranium when we are
importing uranium to Russia and now we
learn she stole a primary election and
the mainstream media doesn't mention an
ABC NBC CBS their evening newscast not
one word about it Herman the last part
of that tweet from President Trump I
think says a lot where is the Justice
Department the answer is the president
is going to be gone for 11 days I
suspect I don't like to speculate that
in 11 days there's gonna be a
come-to-jesus meeting with the Attorney
General Jeff Sessions I like Attorney
General Jeff Sessions I think he is an
honorable honest person relative to his
trade but as Pam said this is about
enforcing the rule of law and if you
break the law you should pay the
consequences I think he's got an 11 day
window to put something on a table
that's gonna bring justice to this whole
situation well and Sean is a state AG of
the third largest state in the country I
can tell you what would be going on if
this was the state issue and this is
what I'm praying is going on right now
in Department of Justice they should
have a war room set up this should be
all hands on deck this is huge this is
not only troubling I mean as you've so
well laid out all the potential criminal
violations and they have got to have
everybody working around the clock which
I'm praying they're doing and I'll tell
you what the good federal investigation
we shouldn't find out about so I'm going
to give them the benefit of the doubt
now
because a great US cetera great Attorney
General for the United States of America
should not be letting us know what's
going on so let's be praying that that
is what's happening that they're all
hands on deck they're working they're
going after this they're researching
this this is what they need to be doing
right now and and I'm hopeful they are
because we do all like Jeff Sessions the
Herman I'll give you the last word here
she stole an election mile violated laws
there she peed for Hillary Clinton
bought and paid for
Russian lies propaganda to influence our
election sold out national security
never makes sense on the Iranian one
deal and the email server scandal it
song incontrovertible to me laws were
broken politically speaking this isn't
really about Hillary it's about do we
have a dual justice system one for
Hillary in the Clintons and her cronies
and one for the rest of us if you look
at the eight years of the Obama
administration they worked overtime to
shove all of this stuff under the carpet
well it's not under the carpet anymore
and we have a different president and as
you indicated as much as I like Jeff
Sessions he should either step down but
in eleven days if he does not he may get
asked to step down and here's why if you
bring in a new Attorney General he is
not bound by recusing himself he's not
bound he or she not bound by in the past
promises and this way the Justice
Department can do the things that it
ought to be doing in order to basically
investigate and convict Hillary Clinton
and the Clinton Foundation alright guys
thank you